the dismal swamp is an environment that
has hazardous conditions associated with
it the heat you got poisonous snakes and
mosquitoes come out at certain times of
the year and it's unbearable but when
you think about some of the torture the
enslaved people's endured
I think if most of us were living during
that day and we had an option to go in
the swamp and live freely I think a lot
of us would take that option
[Music]
from the 17th century until the Civil
War escaped slaves known as Marines
found refuge in the Great Dismal Swamp
located on the border of Virginia and
North Carolina the swamp was wild and
inhospitable nevertheless it was there
that Runaways created self-sufficient
communities almost entirely cut off from
the outside world for the past 10 years
archaeologist Dan sayers from American
University has been studying these
settlements part of what I did was
develop this sort of research program
called the Great Dismal Swamp landscape
study most of my focus has been on
archaeological discovery of sites out
the swamp as well as historical research
and then of course trying to understand
it before we start our research there
was a sense people lived in the swamp
for a variety of reasons but we really
wanted to go in the swamp and find
remnants of their lives out there and
sure enough that we've been able to look
at several sites associate several of
these different groups probably in 1792
18 25 or 30 nail that we found
resistance
I'm sure the population went up and down
but very strong potential for any given
moment for thousands of people that they
went out of the Great Dismal inform
these multi-generational communities it
was a radical form of resistance in a
good way
The Runaways was game slavery risked
everything to be free even if it meant
living in the harsh environment of the
swamp one former slave who briefly lived
in the swamp was a man named Moses
grandi I've done family genealogy
research in which I've uncovered a slave
narrative by Moses grandi who I believe
is my great-great grandfather's uncle
this Edmond granted my great-great
grandfather's headstone who was born in
1827 he was a Waterman and a Boltzmann
on the dismal swamp canal which was
being hand dug and he describes very
vividly in the slave narrative how they
were treated what they endured how they
were tortured if you had that kind of
experience and you had an opportunity to
come out to the swamp and live freely
under you know challenging conditions
you're gonna have a hard time getting
them out of there the idea of Africans
setting up communities and being in in
charge of their destiny in the swamp I
don't want people to ever forget this
history
[Music]